let's now extend our concept of momentum
to a system of particles again we need
to choose a reference frame so we'll
have a ground frame and let's consider n
particles now when we have a lot of
particles we need some type of notation
so let's use the symbol J and it will go
from 1 to N and then our arbitrary J
particle will be moving this particle
will have mass M J and it will be moving
with the velocity V J now recall in our
system we have many other particles we
can call that one one this one and we
have lots of different particles in the
system and this just represents an
arbitrary particle in that system and
the momentum of the Jade particle is
just the mass mg a times the velocity V
J and again we're assuming some fixed
reference frame so the total momentum of
the system we now have to add up the
momentum of all the particles all the
way up to the nth particle now when we
make a sum like this there's a standard
mathematical summation notation which
will write like this we'll do the sum
this capital Sigma C of J goes from 1 to
J goes to n of the momentum of the Jade
particle and that represents the sum j
goes from 1 to n of m j bj and this is
what we call the momentum of the system
this is a vector sum and now let's see
how Newton's second law applies to the
momentum of the system suppose that
acting on our particles for instance
here's our j DH article we have a force
FJ acting on the
particle then we know that from Newton's
law that the force will be also the sum
of the forces on all the particles F 1 F
2 plus dot dot dot plus F n so once
again we can write this as a sum J goes
from 1 to N of the force on the j 'the
particle and that's the force on the
summing of all the forces on all the
particles in the system but now we can
apply Newton's second law so Newton's
second law is the statement that the
force on the J the particle causes the
momentum of the J the particle to change
and when we write that now the total
force on the system J goes from 1 to N
is just the sum of the change in
momentum because every single term let's
just look at that T 1 plus DP 2 DT plus
dot dot plus DP and DT that's what we
mean by the sum we can rewrite this as D
by DT of P 1 plus P 2 plus P 3 plus dot
dot plus P N and what we see is that the
total force is the derivative of the sum
J goes from 1 to N of the momentum but
recall this sum we've defined as the
momentum of the system so our conclusion
is the total force causes the momentum
of the system to change
now so far all we've done is we've
recast Newton's second law in this form
our next step is to analyze the forces
on the individual particles we have an
apply Newton's third law so we'll do
that next